結構長い期間　僕この家に住んでまして
この家も賃貸なんで
大家さんって人がいます
建物とか管理してる人ね。
この家に住んで　僕ももう
二年か三年くらいなんですけどぉ
多分、史上最強に
迷惑かけてるなと思っておりまして
ホント　申し訳無さが 半端ないんですけど
特にことしですね　もｳ　今年は
なんか小・中学生がウチに来て叫んだり
わけわからないものを たくさん送られて来たり
そして もう 最後には ストーカーが来たり
警察が沢山来たりして スゴイ迷惑をかけたので
ここにいたら　ダメなんじゃねが ぐらいに思ってまして
その中！
大家さんに呼び出しをくらいました…
★デーン★
行って来ます★
笑っちゃダメなんだよな　ﾎﾝﾄに
オレ なんなんだろ どうなんだろ
じゃあ　行って来ます
すぅー
やばい ｱｰｱｧｰ    ﾀﾞﾒﾀﾞﾒﾀﾞﾒﾀﾞﾒ　戻って　ﾊｲ 戻って
戻って　はい　戻って
ｽｲﾔｾﾝ　失礼しま〜す
大家さん）は〜い
大家さん)　あーぁー
大家さん）はいどうぞ　お疲れ様で〜す
はじめ）お疲れ様で〜す
さあ　一体…?
嗚呼　よかったぁ！
ｽｲﾔｾﾝ
大家さん）最近さ　いろんなことあって
はじめ）ア　ソーナンスよ
ｽｲﾔｾﾝ　ありがとうございます
今日 折角 大家さんとお話しできるタイミングが
できそうなので　順々に僕が気になってることを→
大家さん）あ　どうぞ　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　はじめ）→聞いてもいいですか？
はじめ）改まって緊張しますね
はじめ）いつもお世話になってます
はじめ）とりあえず 今年も一年ありがとうございます
大家さん）こちらこそありがとうございます
はじめ）何年ぶりでしたっけ この家に来たの
はじめ）もう　三年‥？　　　　　　　　　　　　　　大家さん）もう,三年かな
はじめ）ｲﾔ　もっとか？
はじめ）三年以上ですね
はじめ）せっかくこの機会なので 聞いてみたいんですけど
はじめ）今年結構　色々あったじゃないですか〜
はじめ）めちゃくちゃ知らない荷物 届けられたり〜
はじめ）もう　中学生が叫んだりして
ストーカー来たりして～
はじめ）心配が…
大家さん）言葉選ばないといけないんですけど
はじめ）あ　もう 全然
はじめ）ホントですか？
大家さん）事前にありましたでしょ？
大家さん）付けたでしょ？防犯カメラ　　　　　　　　はじめ）あぁ そうですね
はじめ）そうです　防犯カメラ家につけたって言ったんですけど
はじめ）あれも大家さんと相談して
大家さん）あの　ウチ全然関係ないです
はじめ）ホントですか
大家さん）一万棟も二万棟もマンションを経営しているわけではないので
そうすると、最大公約数を「全く」求めてないので、
特徴のあるものをつくっているだけなので
はじめ）僕はすごい心配していて
大家さん）あ～確かに
はじめ）僕も家でいろいろﾄﾞﾝﾁｬﾝ騒ぎやってるわけじゃないですか
そういうのを見ると、なんか他の大家さんだと
YouTuberを入れたくないみたいな人は、
大家さん) 多少どんちゃん騒ぎあっても
隣に全く影響のないつくりをしています
そーなんすよ、そこがすごいありがたいです
あざっす！いやーなんか今年いろいろあったんで・・・
まぁいろんな方にご迷惑を
おかけしつつも
僕が一番
ご迷惑をお掛けしたのが大家さんなのかなていう
大家さん) はじめさんの知らないところでケアができればなぁと思います
大家さん) でも最近小学生少なくなりましたよね
アーうちに上がりに来る奴らですか
僕結構注意してるんすよ
おまえふざけんじゃねぇぞ
って注意して追い返してるんで
大家さん) 夏なんかここに来ましたもんね。間違えて
ほんとですか！申し訳ありません。
はっはっはー
大家さんの気持ちを知りたっかたなっていうところが
大家さん) いつでも声かけていつでも出るから
どっきりいいって
大家さん) 末永く はじめん) あーこちらこそ
この素晴らしい建物と
大家さんの人の好さで
ほんとに僕助かってるんで、今後ともよろしくおねがいします‼
あはははは
またよろしくお願いします！！今年もありがとうございました
♪) テレレレーレ
来年もよろしくお願いします
大家さんサイコー！